now let's figure out how much the single
person making $50,000 a year would pay
in state income taxes assuming that
they're in a state that has income taxes
and this right here the current tax
brackets for my state and every state
will have different income tax brackets
and they're likely to change year after
year but the important thing to take
away is just how all of this is
calculated so at the state level you
still get you still or at least the
state I'm in there is a standard
deduction it's three thousand seven
hundred and sixty nine dollars for a
single filer for a single person and
instead of having a personal exemption
which reduces your taxable income which
is what we saw at the federal level they
have a tax credit a personal tax credit
which is essentially just a credit on
your taxes so this doesn't reduce your
taxable income this can actually be used
against the actual taxes that you owe so
first let's think about what our taxable
income is in my state so I'm starting
with $50,000 $50,000 is my gross income
and then I have a standard deduction in
my state a standard deduction in my
state of three thousand seven hundred
and sixty nine three thousand seven
hundred and sixty nine dollars gets me
two taxable income in my state of forty
six thousand dollars two hundred and
thirty one or forty six thousand two
hundred and thirty one dollars now if
you look at these brackets it looks like
we are falling into this eight percent
bracket right over here but just as we
said in this in the federal example that
does not mean we pay eight percent on
all 46 thousand forty six thousand two
hundred and thirty one dollars
it means we only pay the eight percent
on the increment above 37 thousand and
five dollars therefore the rest of the
brackets we pay one percent on the first
seven thousand words first seven
thousand one hundred twenty four 2% on
the increment up to 16 thousand nine
hundred eighty so on and so forth so
let's calculate what that is so we are
going to pay we are going to pay one
percent one percent on the first seven
thousand one hundred and twenty four
dollars then to that we're gonna pay two
percent we're gonna pay 2% on the
increment up to sixteen thousand nine
hundred and eighty dollars and that
increment is sixteen nine eighty minus
seven thousand one hundred and twenty
four dollars and then we are going to
a 4% we're going to pay 4% on the
increment up to twenty six thousand six
hundred and fifty seven dollars and so
that's that number minus sixteen
thousand eight hundred and ninety and
then we are going to pay six percent we
are going to pay six percent on the
increment up to thirty seven thousand
and five dollars just thirty seven
thousand five minus twenty six six five
seven and then we're in the homestretch
here we're gonna pay we're gonna pay
eight percent on the increment on the
increment above thirty seven thousand
and five dollars so our taxable income
we already saw is forty six thousand to
thirty one so it's forty six thousand to
thirty one minus thirty seven thousand
five thirty seven thousand five brings
us to did I type all of that in right
let's see seven times one percent and
then we have two percent times that
looks right then we have four percent I
want to make sure I'm typing all this in
correctly and then thirty seven thousand
minus twenty six six 57 and then at six
percent and then eight percent on that
last increment drum roll please
we get to 2018 dollars just based on the
brackets right over here so two thousand
so at the at the state level at the
state level it looks like we have two
thousand and eighteen dollars just based
on our taxable income but now we have to
factor in this tax credit and a tax
credit as opposed to a deduction
remember a deduction or an exemption
takes it reduces your taxable income a
credit goes directly against your taxes
so we were gonna pay 2018 but we get it
we get a credit of 102 dollars which
gets us to what that gets us to 1916
1916 dollars in state taxes so our total
taxes 9750 for the federal level 1916 at
the
state level and so our actual take-home
pay is going to be you see fifty
thousand is what we're starting with
we're gonna pay we're gonna pay at the
federal level actually ready figured out
in the last video what we're left with
but at the federal level going to start
up we're gonna pay nine thousand seven
hundred and fifty four then at the state
level we're gonna pay 1916 getting us to
thirty eight thousand three thirty
take-home pay thirty eight thousand
three thirty three thirty is what I'm
actually I'm actually going to be able
to spend and so based on this we can
figure out what an effective tax rate is
based on both the federal and state
income tax so we are if we look at that
as a fraction of our original income
fifty thousand we are left with seventy
six point six percent or another way of
thinking about it is roughly twenty
three point four or twenty three and a
third percent of your income gets taken
for taxes that is your effective tax
rate so effective tax rate we write this
effective effective tax rate and then we
are including both federal federal plus
state federal plus state just look at
the number again you're keeping seventy
six point six so you are paying twenty
three point four twenty three point
actually looks like twenty three point
three four so approximately twenty three
approximately twenty three percent if
you want think out on a monthly basis at
fifty thousand dollars you thought so
fifty thousand dollars
you thought that you would be taking
home 4166 a month but now you're
actually going to be taking home three
thousand thirty eight thousand three
hundred and thirty divided by twelve
you're only going to bring home about
three thousand a little bit under thirty
two hundred a month so you have to plan
accordingly